ladies and gentlemen we have the
decoration of the result of the poll for
the election of a Member of Parliament
force a Swindon I Stephen Peter Taylor
be in the act in returning officer at
this election do hereby give notice that
the number of votes recorded for each
candidate at this election is as follows
Robert James Buckland the Conservative
Party candidate twenty four thousand
eight hundred and nine Sarah church
labor and co-operative party twenty 2345
[Applause]
marking for Costello UK independent
party 1291 Calais Kimberley Fairburn the
Green Party 747 and Stanley Jane
Heydrich Liberal Democrat 2079 and there
were 87 ballot papers rejected and
though and I do hereby declare the
Robert Jane Buckland if you'll elected
as a member of parliament for South
Sweden
thank you very much indeed thank you
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to thank
the returning officer in the outstanding
swindon counting team for having
delivered an expeditious and I would say
excellent result I'd like to thank my
opponents all of them for a courteous
and civilized campaign it's been hard
fought it's been hard won but I want to
pay my tribute to all of them for
upholding the best traditions of our
great British democracy I'd like to
thank the police for keeping us safe at
a time when we have seen some of the
most turbulent extraordinary and frankly
frightening events in our living memory
not just here but in the rest of the
world we face the unprecedented
peacetime challenge of brexit the threat
of terrorism at home and abroad the
constant pressure placed upon government
by the need to balance the importance of
public spending on our public services
and our outstanding debt and all the
other day-to-day challenges of
government that I see at first hand a
Solicitor General the election night is
still very young so I'm not going to
even begin to presume to predict the
final outcome it is of course my fervent
hope that that outcome will produce the
majority Conservative government that I
believe this country needs and a sense
of bringing the country together in a
way that perhaps we have not seen for
too long now and I say to all my friends
like me who voted remain and indeed to
all my friends who voted leave but it is
now time to come together and give
Britain the brexit that we deserve a
sensible outcome that protects our
industries both here in Swindon and more
widely and also protects the rights and
obligations that have been so dearly won
whether it relates to workers the
environment and a range of other
benefits that cooperation has brought us
what I can say with absolute certainty
is that my work in representing my
fellow residents here in South Swindon
will go on and I will continue to stand
up for our town every step of the way we
fought a positive local campaign and I'm
extremely proud of my outstanding and
dedicated local team my agent and
campaign manager Nick burns Howell
deserves special thanks and praise for
his hard work and dedication and I'd
like to further dedicate my win to the
late Geoffrey halls our chairman and
agent who would have so loved this
result tonight and I finally I also owe
my thanks my personal thanks to my wife
and my family for their continuing
unstinting support without which I
simply could not go on finally my thanks
to every fellow resident who gave me
their vote of this election and indeed
my thanks to every resident in Swindon
because whatever your vote I will
continue to serve you as your MP it is
an honor and a privilege to represent
such a wonderful constituency and I look
forward to serving both it and indeed my
country in the months and years ahead
thank you
[Applause]